everything kind of got messed up for the
last big stop which was kind of the draw
of the trip was it at least postable on
Instagram I don't think I posted it I
think I was that mad I'm Elizabeth South
I'm a private investigator with cane
associates investigations here in Los
Angeles California John you think
that'll help me yeah it better this is
John
yeah I'm John this time we're playing
two truths and a lie regarding exotic
travel stories let's smoke out a liar hi
I'm Jennifer and I almost got kidnapped
in China trying to go to the Great Wall
four hours away from Beijing hi I'm
Kelsey and I was searched by the Italian
police my name is Kate and I was lost
out of bounds in the backcountry on a
mountain in Whistler well let's go ahead
and start with you since you're over
here to the side I was kind of crazy
China yeah all right so you were almost
kidnapped I was trying to get to this
great part of the wall called samhitas
it was the only place on the Great Wall
where there was no tourist attraction so
I went on a little adventure and asked
around people who didn't speak English
to help me out and I was crazy I had one
moment where I had a guy follow me for
15 minutes trying to get me to go into
his car and he had like five guys
waiting so he spoke English names like
come to my car he was like saying you
know come to the wall I will take you
there
or come with me I'll take you wherever
you need to go and you know obviously
you don't want to go with someone who
just says come with me so and this whole
China trip was just you just me I went
on a backpacking trip for six months and
China was my first that was part of it
yeah that was the beginning of the whole
that was the beginning of that yeah
you're three days into a hundred and
eighty day adventure yeah almost yeah so
was that the almost this this guy like
yeah I was it would kind of happen twice
I actually got lost I was really
frustrated and one guy like saw my
frustration try to help me out but he
was like you should just come with me
and then I was like no no thank you and
then for 15 minutes I was walking around
the city he actually followed me and
you know that you were watching him like
yeah he's like yeah I'm still here I
want you to come with me you should come
with me and I really persistent in
English she was saying this well I mean
real Kaneko broken English yeah okay did
you get like a weird feeling inside yeah
my intuition told me I need to stay away
from these men I don't know who they
were it didn't seem right felt really
shady no matter how lost I Allah I was
lost I was lost and I kind of like I'm
like a guy I'm can always take out your
phone because people that are bad don't
like to be photographed yeah or video
you like hey yeah say hi to all my
followers on Instagram hey look here's a
great idea
yeah great advice I actually will maybe
do that next time someone tries to
follow me so did you ever make it to the
Great Wall I did I actually met a really
really nice guy on the bus he knew
everything about this part of the Great
Wall he was probably trying to kidnap
you know he was like the nerdiest like
Chinese guy ever mad but he was so nice
he was just really nice and it was it
felt more like okay I could trust him
and he took me to the Great Wall they
had like a cable car ride you can like
ride down it's a two-hour hike so
beautiful I had a beautiful lake right
next to it most of the smog is out too
so you can actually see the wall and
what was this last year this was three
three and a half years ago oh okay
baby beatniks okay let's hear your story
I was traveling in Italy and I was there
with two of my friends from my study
abroad program and we were going to do
this bus tour which was not my idea cuz
I'm not a bus tour kind of gal but we
were trying to go to different like
little cities around the countryside and
we the end was to go to like Pisa and
see the Leaning Tower and everything
well one one of the small little stops I
was like had like an ice-cream place I
think it was that one yeah this isn't
Pisa
no it was right before Pisa so we
stopped there we got our little gelato
and then we cut back on the bus and some
other tourists realized that their
phones were missing and instead of
thinking that it was pickpockets
they assumed that it was someone on the
bus stole their stuff and so then they
called the Italian police the bus was
pulled over they had us all get off and
then they
searched every single member of us and
the sun's like setting and we were like
no and so by the time we got everybody
back on the bus and finished being
searched we finally got to Pisa and
everything was closed and so it was all
like dark I wasn't I don't even remember
but it was after dark so that like all
of the restaurants mostly I'd closed
down because it's a very tourist
attraction because Pisa you can normally
eat there until about 10:00 10:30 at
night it's been a bit of time there so
it might have been later than that just
curious I know
I don't honestly remember I just
remember being mad when was this it was
my junior
it was my Earl like the first semester
junior year of like college so what was
your major in college I was an acting
major so but you just took this trip to
Italy I studied abroad and during my
trip abroad we took a trip to Italy
where'd you study abroad I was studying
in London okay and so they're like okay
you can do this little trip to Italy and
we had like a spring break or something
like that or maybe it was a I mean yeah
it would be spring break because it was
at the top of the year or something I
don't even remember so sorry I have to
ask sure
when was junior year I would have to
think I'm so bad at remembering dates I
graduated college in 2014 so it'll
probably have been 2013 2012 okay cool
thank you yeah it was not a recent trip
so I don't remember all of the the great
details all right hmm
I'm pretty good on questions for you I
may come back okay yeah now my dear yes
number three so in 2012 I went to the
Vancouver Olympics for work and while I
was there we were working on a film so
we went with a famous backcountry
freestyle skier and we took a helicopter
I opened the mountains I was dropped off
at a certain point to be able to capture
the moment of them coming down the slope
so I was waiting there alone which at 22
I was didn't think twice about it so I
was supposed to be there for about 45
minutes but it was an hour then it was
an hour and a half then it was two hours
and threw out of range so now I'm
getting nervous about where they are and
if something's happened to them and then
I started to realize oh I'm actually
the side of a mountain can't contact
anyone
I couldn't ski down from where I was
also when you're at that level even
though you're surrounded by snow the Sun
is extremely hot and it you can see I
have fair skin so I didn't have a lot to
cover myself up other than my ski gear
except that it was so hot I had to take
it off what time of day was this it was
around like two to three and what
happened he was trying to take them down
the regular way that he would go down so
since they couldn't go down that way
they had to find another route which is
why there was a delay I have a question
what you were you born what year was I
born yeah 1986 okay
she's like I don't know how that's okay
but okay so going across all of these my
impressions are you are really confident
about your story and you really get
excited about telling it like you're
happy to be here and like talk about
this story confident once you tell
everything to like yeah it was like this
they lie a lot of times too it's gonna
be careful you did take a pretty long
big been awhile keep an eye out for that
so trying to refresh memories sure it's
been even longer you know maybe it never
happened it's almost all of a sudden
there's two guys trying to kidnap her
it's like wow guys I'm sorry it was one
one kidnapping it was a guy in four guys
in a club then there's two kidnapping
attempt so then if you ask me there's a
third kidnapping attempt but the third
guy was a nurse so he couldn't possibly
be kidnap so I don't know you you're a
little bit sketch on the way you looked
around and said some things but I think
that there were definitely parts of the
story that were true but I'm not really
buying it even if it is true and you're
the only one who looked at the other
girl to tell a story they just looked at
us the whole time
and you I feel like she kind of looks
guilty but I'm not sure she is guilty of
lying so you mentioned that this was in
2012 for the Winter Olympics 2010 right
okay so you said 2012 oh you also said
at the time you were 22 yeah if you were
born in 1986 you would have been 24 in
2010 or 26 in 2012 so you wouldn't have
been to one
- that's not a hard-and-fast definitive
indicator but something doesn't line up
but i'm going between these two I'm
gonna have to disagree I'm gonna cast my
vote for Kate I'm gonna go with the
Italian story okay I think I think
Kate's got some holes in our story well
I feel good I'm still batting below 500
but yeah it's it's good to win one for
once I needed this
[Music]